the fall elections are less than four
months from today tempers will rise even
higher than they are now that is
guaranteed something awful could easily
happen now right now is the time for
progressive leaders to douse the fires
that they set to calm their inflamed
supporters it is vital they do that and
yet they're doing the opposite now
they're telling their followers that the
President of the United States is a
Russian spy a traitor the penalty for
treason is death
traitors of course must be overthrown
the mob screams wild with rage Democrats
are banking that that rage will get
their voters to the polls in November
and they may be right it may it may also
destroy the country
Robert butea was a radio host and an
attorney and he joins us tonight Robert
thank you for coming on I have a
question that I've wanted to ask for a
long time someone on the left why the
flag burning in the attacks on America
what is this protest very often devolve
into an attack on the country itself it
symbols this chant America was never
great your founding fathers owned slaves
why attack the whole country well I
think you can find it Stream Istanbul
the left and the right who do things
they're anti-american the same way you
have these protesters you'll have the
Charlottesville protesters on the other
hand who are anti-american I don't
support any of these people who if you
don't like America get out of America if
you're a neo-nazi get out of America but
there's but hold on okay and I think
it's a fair point but the scale is very
different so you have the
Charlottesville riot or whatever it was
last August a year ago you haven't seen
anything like that since the NFL has
been in a continuous controversy over
kneeling during the national anthem an
attack on a national symbol left-wing
protests routinely contain attacks on
the country the t-shirt your country was
never great is for sale online so is the
Hat what is that about I'm not saying
there are no conservatives right-wingers
who don't hate America but there are a
lot on the left to do and they're very
open about it
why and why don't lead errs ever say
anything about it well I think leaders
do and I think it's very easy to find
the clips of the most crazy most extreme
elements of the political discourse
and make that seem like that is the norm
that is not the norm most people or who
are protesting or saying we want
reasonable policies that all Americans
do not King unite around and frankly I
think a large part of this falls on the
president you know President Truman had
a placard on his desk saying the buck
stops here that's what that is what
President Trump had to take up and
understand that he has to bring these
parties together if people are
protesting over the immigration policy
they do like Tip O'Neill and Ronald
Reagan would do and you bring it
together the stakeholders you hammer out
an immigration reform bill you break for
the American people you discuss it and
that will tamp down the vile tamp down
these protests but leaving this vacuum
animation where people think the
children are being kidnapped that's not
gonna work okay so I agree with a lot of
what you're saying actually I do want a
rational conversation about what's best
for the country try to do that every
night on this show it's pretty hard to
do that though when people are saying
not just random protesters in front of a
doughnut shop in West LA but I don't
know the ranking members on the
Democratic side of the House and Senate
are calling the President of the United
States a traitor somebody's committed
treason a death-penalty offense if you
really believe the president was a
Russian agent as elected members of
Congress have said today then how could
you and do anything but try to overthrow
him that's not a predicate for
reasonable discussion is it well
absolutely not but what one thing has to
happen is the president hasn't explained
what the point of the meeting with Putin
was what happened in that meeting with
him for those two hours while there was
no other members of the intelligence
community or national security staff
there with them why he offered to have
Russians interrogate American citizens
so when you have this information vacuum
this falls in a large part on the
president's communication Holden I mean
I could look I could rebut a lot of what
you just said the president can't hand
anybody over to the Russians despite
what Democrats keep saying that it
doesn't work that way you're not allowed
what is he gonna
you know inject them with barbiturates
and throw him on a plane to mom I mean
that's it's ludicrous but I looked at my
job to defend Trump I'm just asking if
you don't know what happened why are you
jumping to the conclusion that he
committed trees
and that's what elected members of
Congress are saying they're using the
word treason if you really believed he
was committing treason why wouldn't you
try to overthrow him or hurt him
Sher Singh but remember but remember
this goes back to the concept of the
book stopping with the president he has
to use his bully pulpit not to bully
people but to articulate a message to
America what do you say if I said if I
said I don't agree with you you're
you've committed treason you're a
traitor
you're a sleeper cell for one of our
enemies what do you say to that
I mean honestly like that's look that's
not what you think at the beginning of a
conversation that is being that's a call
for violence look at our practice
criminal offense every day and what ends
up happening is people accuse your
client of everything under the Sun and
the indictment but what you do is argue
back your point you say that well the
reason I was meeting with Putin was
because we have interest in Syria that
need to be articulated between the two
parties because he actually said work on
gas pipelines he's not getting his
messaging out and when you leave this
vacuum out there that's when you have
members of the Republican Party again
whatever I don't care about the repeal
everyone always says oh the Republicans
say it too I couldn't be less impressed
with them as a groups that means nothing
to me but will you at least concede that
calling someone a traitor is a
conversation ender not a starter and
maybe you should wait for evidence that
a person has betrayed his country before
calling him a traitor is that fair
oh that's best fabulous not pretend that
the last eight years the last 16 years
didn't happen well you have people
exclaiming that Obama was a Kenyan who
was part of a sleeper cells in here and
part of a madrasah
let's understand that this course didn't
start with trumpet lion is very
different of a sleeper cell and while
being a private citizen President Trump
posted birtherism idea for years let's
understand that the buck stops with the
president in order to tap these things
out have a conversation will be merciful
same exact winter trees
buck stops wolf you you are the leader
of the free point but I write I
appreciate I appreciate part of what
you're trying to say but I don't
understand the rest Robert it's nice to
see you tonight thank you for coming on
thanks Tucker